well let's jump into this first story
here we go ladies and gentlemen from
Reuters Georgia charges Trump and former
advisers in 2020 election case hey hold
on there a minute Reuters those were
lawyers not advisors I guess you can
technically say that they were advisors
because they gave him legal advice as
lawyers but that's constitutionally
protected what does Michael malice call
this factual but not truthful yes it's
factual they advised him but they're
lawyers
former U.S president Donald Trump was
hit with a sweeping fourth set of
criminal charges on Monday when a
Georgia grand jury issued an indictment
accusing him of efforts to overturn his
2020 election laws to Democrat Joe Biden
to 98 indictment listing 19 defendants
and 41 criminal counts now
last night we talked about how
The Fulton County Court released the
indictment against Donald Trump
prematurely took it down called it a
fictitious document and denied it now
what they're saying it was it was a
sample document and it accidentally got
published it should never have happened
so uh they lied then or they're lying
now take your pick I think it's fairly
obvious they were planning to indict
Trump uh bring these charges against him
well before a grand jury was convened
and more importantly
they could have done it years ago it is
being done today for political purposes
I want to show you the indictment and
some of the more silly elements of it
but the seriousness of it can be
explained right here on the front page
Fulton Superior Court
the state of Georgia versus Donald John
Trump Rudolph Giuliani who I believe was
his lawyer John Eastman also a lawyer
Mark Meadows that was uh Trump's who's
the chief of chief of staff that was
Mark Meadows
uh you've got uh who else do we have
Kenneth chaseborough I believe was a
lawyer Jeffrey Clark was a state
department attorney Jenna Ellis was also
an attorney interestingly Jenna Alice
has been rather anti-trump over the past
several months and has been somewhat
crit has been critical of him now but
also supporting DeSantis also people are
pulling up very old posts from her where
she was very anti-trump early on
Ray Smith Robert cheely Michael Roman
David Shafer David Shaffer that one's
actually fairly interesting because he
met with an alternate slate of electors
then told the press all that matters is
if the court cases proceed they'll have
an alternate slate of electors for that
he's being criminally charged Sean still
Stephen Lee Harrison Floyd
trevian uh trevian cootie this is funny
because that's uh Kanye West's publicist
apparently she had advocated on behalf
of the Trump campaign to an election
official that they should pursue an
investigation into voting machines
that's a criminal conspiracy
Sydney Powell yep Kathleen Latham who I
believe was one of the election
officials who opened the door for the
Trump campaign in Coffee County Scott
Hall and Misty Hampton another election
official I believe opened the door
so what you have here
you have a state department attorney
being criminally charged you have a
series of lawyers being criminally
charged Mark Meadows was the chief of
staff of Donald he was rejected yeah
okay that's what I thought I thought I
thought I was right wanted to be sure
though
criminally charged in Georgia why
because of a legal Theory pertaining to
what the vice president is or isn't
allowed to do here's my view
Mike Pence does have the authority to
reject votes in the electoral vote count
Richard Nixon had done it before he
chose Democrat votes over Republican
votes despite the fact that Democrats
were certified as in 1960. so using that
legal Theory and precedent Mike Pence
would have been able to do it well Mike
Pence didn't do it there you go whatever
you don't gotta like the guy a lot of
people don't like the guy but that's it
they had they had a legal Theory and
plan they asked Mike Pence he said no
it's over now we can see exactly why
Mike Pence refused to engage I'm willing
to bet they went him and said if you go
along with this you will be arrested you
will be charged and we will destroy
everything about your life the
interesting thing is they kept making
the argument the vice president had no
authority to do this and then Mike Pence
made the mistake of doing a TV uh
interview recently where he said I could
have pushed the votes back and it would
have gone to the state uh to to the
house delegations the house House of
Representatives so he knew exactly what
his authority and Powers were there were
numerous articles written by left-wing
personalities journalists where they
explained if Mike Pence rejected
electoral votes then house delegations
would vote for the president that's the
normal procedure so Mike Pence Democrats
the media everybody began lying saying
he never had the authority to do so in
the first place which wasn't true they
then changed the laws later on to say
yeah he can't do that by the time he
could so what we were really looking at
was nothing criminal but legal Theory
the next people in my view who will face
criminal indictments
television media political high-level
influential personalities who are in
communication with Donald Trump or his
lawyers who then went on Twitter Youtube
Fox News whatever and advocated for
these election strategies advocated for
legal challenges and to find uh votes
advocated for the Dominion claims and
additionally those who encouraged
protest on January 6th and those who
cheered on January 6th there are a lot
of people I'm not going to name them let
this be their own business
that pre-january 6 were cheering saying
yes yes people should go down and saying
that people should engage in certain
behaviors
then January 6 happened
some people actually cheered on what
happened that day on social media saying
why are people mad about this you've had
leftists the gravel Institute cheered
for January 6 not that they advocated
for it
months go by a year goes by and you may
notice that some of these personalities
became hardcore to Santa supporters and
absolutely anti-trump
I think there's a very obvious reason
why they were crying and shaking and
begging in in hopes that if they turn on
Trump the doj the state level uh
prosecutors will Overlook them and not
criminally charge them now I can't say
who uh necessarily holds those I think
it's I think many of the people who
turned on Trump probably felt that way
I'm not going to say I can tell you
definitively any of these individuals I
will however point out Jenna Ellis who
turned on Trump recently has been
advocating heavily for Ron DeSantis and
is now facing criminal charges and is
trying to raise money the sad thing here
is that Ardent Trump supporters are not
the biggest fans of Jenna Ellis now and
so she has no support she's raised a few
thousand dollars for her legal defense I
think she deserves a legal defense but
by turning on Trump and trying to go
into the Santa's Camp you're looking at
mustering up what 10 of the GOP yeah
but does it matter at this point like if
you supported that from the beginning
and then you like last minute ditch
effort like oh I'm gonna support the
Santas in hopes that I'm not gonna get
in trouble I mean obviously it doesn't
matter right it's an ancient struggle
session tactic to get someone to
denounce their own views publicly before
you serve theirs before we take them to
sentence Socrates refuse to do it he
spoke the truth until the moment he died
um some people you know it is an old it
is an old battle tactic an authoritarian
tactic to get the crowd because then you
can say well they admitted it so
right she you know she whatever they're
charging them under Rico what does that
mean criminal Enterprise saying that was
a criminal organization that was
conspiring to engage in illegal
behaviors I think it's that is
ridiculous and I mean the whole thing in
my opinion is ridiculous I don't think
anybody that's charged Donald Trump is a
republican at all right the entire thing
is Democrats right uh well no they
didn't they say Jackson who's is Jack
Smith a Democrat
look you had a republican go on TV in in
uh in Georgia and be like Trump ruin the
Republican party yeah you've got Neo
party you've got tokens neocon and
uniparty shells I want to read for you
act 22 of the indictment
they say on or about the third day of
December 2020. Donald John Trump caused
to be tweeted from the Twitter account
at realdonaldtrump quote Georgia
hearings now on oannn Amazing this was
an overt act in furtherance of the
conspiracy
now a lot of people have said there are
a lot of Provisions in here about
tweeting and one of what's insulting
Mike Pence calling him a wimp or
something like that and that uh these
were illegal activities no no these
aren't illegal actions they are arguing
that Trump tweeting proves he was
engaged in a conspiracy that he was
advancing his conspiracy by tweeting
this that's so ridiculous to eat to
attempt to to to to to defend yourself
or or use the means that your legal
means at your disposal to try to affect
an outcome like it's the point was that
these means were legal to try to say hey
let's recount you know to see if there
was some kind of uh some kind of fraud
that's perfectly legal the fact that
they're trying to prosecute I think I
honestly think the fact that they're
trying to prosecute people that were in
any way in business with Trump or or on
team Trump is this essentially boils
down to and this might seem a little
hyperbolic but essentially was down to
the same reason that they just smoked
the dude in in Utah I think that the 75
year old dude that was making threats
about the president they could have
wrapped him up the guy could barely walk
they could have kicked in his door and
got him without killing him they didn't
have to drag his body out and leave him
laying on the sidewalk you know like
they didn't have to do that there was an
intent there which is to intimidate the
American people or intimidate people
that are anti-establishment and the same
thing is going on I think for the people
that have worked with with Donald Trump
they're trying to intimidate people that
are anti-establishment saying look if
you would help people that are against
the establishment against whatever you
want to call it whether you want to call
the Deep State you want to call it the
bureaucracy I don't give a crap what
name you put on it but if you're against
that then we're going to unleash as much
uh you know effort or as much of
attention as it requires to neutralize
you and it's the biggest most powerful
government in history it can do multiple
things at once taking care of you your
your issues is that they can do that and
still do all the all the all the same
stuff that they they have planned so
it's not it's not some kind of problem
for them to shut down shut people up or
to shut people down or or to intimidate
people into silence do you think there
are any personalities who got visits
from Democrats law enforcement and we're
told you're gonna come out against
Donald Trump or we're gonna come after
you I'm sure I and probably the bigger
personalities right I don't think yeah
the big personality is so but then it it
you know it trickles down a little bit
too because then you have the small
small time right like
someone like me who's on Instagram or
any of us that are on other social media
platforms that by the way the Biden
Administration is using young gen Z
influencers to his Advantage where we
don't or where the conservatives don't
but could they go after us too then
could they go up to the little guy's
show they do it all the time by Banning
your accounts that's what they're doing
I think that I think I honestly do think
this is all about intimidation I think
that the reason that like I said that
the dude in Utah got smoked I think the
reason they're going after all of the
the people that that were Associates of
trump and stuff like that I think that
it's something that that the
establishment wants look they've said
clearly after January 6 there were
members former members of the
intelligence uh apparatus uh I forget
the guy's name I think it was Brandon
was the guy that was on but he was
talking he's like anyone that has
anti-government uh opinions or your you
know feelings everyone in America that
is right of Center to some degree is
anti-American or anti-government right
they want smaller government even people
that are like establishment
right-leaning people there's ostensibly
smaller government but like anyone
that's like a Maga person or a
Libertarian or any kind of anarchist or
or Independents that want to limit the
uh the military-industrial complex or
people that want to limit limit the uh
the security State and the the the
surveillance apparatus all of those
people are the enemy of the government
now but the problem is I want a healthy
government and if that means it needs to
slim down because the government has
become obese I'm okay with the
government going on a workout program
that's the problem I don't I don't agree
if the government wants to preserve
itself it needs to take itself seriously
and restructure itself
that's why we need to restructure from
time to time how do we do that well
Vivek ramaswamy suggests that we cut the
FBI I think it's the FBI and then send a
lot of the you know fire a lot of the
administration Traders administrative
guys you know but then move a lot of the
necessary pieces to other parts of
government Homeland Security CIA
um Department of energy he has it listed
in fact and I retweeted it it's on
Twitter I'd love to point you to it I'm
on I'm on the same page with you homie
Vivek is great like I I think that he's
a great candidate and I think nobody
ever say his name the cake man we gotta
call him the cake man because it's the
vague like cake you gotta call him the
cake man so if that'll stick but to get
people to remember anybody that runs or
anybody that has an opposing opinion
from it this is my opinion from this
current Administration or the left is
automatically just they're like no no no
no because they've now thrown out all
these racist homophobic xenophobic like
all these words if you're for some
reason anti-government we're seeing it
now that people are thinking that the
American flag makes you racist and like
it's just it's a never-ending Pro no
matter who you are if you come out
against the current Administration
you're wrong whether it's 5x
sorry about that of a fake he forgives
you yes thank you uh or anybody else you
know I mean they're even doing it to
Kennedy and he's one of them it's I
think I wanna it's important to remember
that anti-government and smaller
government is not the same thing you
need a healthy government sometimes it
needs to be smaller or larger to make it
healthy but if you love your government
you want it to be the healthiest it can
be and that means sometimes slimming
down the blow
oh I don't swear love the government
what's the love about the government
yeah not really it's a chance for us to
you know coordinate National Defense and
protect each other it's military and
economic Transportation I don't like I
don't want I mean well I mean obviously
I'm I'm as a Libertarian kind of leaning
kind of guy I want the small the smaller
government so as much cutting as you can
do I'm going to be down with so
I want to show you a few examples uh so
we did get a Super Chat uh virtual rifle
says read act 156 there's a handful of
uh of Acts in this in further into the
conspiracy
one of them is a good example act 156
Donald John Trump committed the felony
fence of a solicitation of violation of
Oath by public officer when he said to
Brad raffensberger a public officer
quote decertif uh he uh I'm sorry he
said uh I want to make sure that I'll
just read it uh public officer he asked
him to engage in conduct constituting
the felony offense of violation of Oath
by public officer by unlawfully quote
decertifying the election or whatever
the correct legal remedy is and announce
the true winner in willful and
intentional violation of the terms of
the oath of said person as prescribed by
law
that's probably the perfect example of
what this is Donald Trump said to the
Secretary of State
engage in the correct legal remedy for
what is going on and that is a is a
violation of your oath of office or
solicitation of violation of us to ask
someone to enact correct legal remedies
in fact he said do a thing which may or
may not have been legal or the correct
legal remedy meaning if the thing was
illegal you instead do the collect
correct legal remedy so how is asking
someone to do a legal remedy
illegal because they are just indicting
it's it's
indictments don't matter as we've
pointed out time and time again women
aren't legally allowed to skydive in
Florida on Sunday ain't no woman's
getting arrested for that right
disorderly conduct what does that mean
yeah exactly I've seen people in the
moment engaged in free speech be
criminally charged with disorderly
conduct
that's a charge they can slap on anyone
for any reason at any time
and then they can arrest you remove you
and then maybe you go to court and you
say your honor I was just speaking and
the judge says okay you're free to go
but you still got locked up
if you don't get bail you could be in
there for a month or longer if you get
locked up on the weekend on a Friday
you're there over the weekend
that sounds what you just read about
that of him asking a guy to do the legal
remedy and then they're saying that what
he did was illegal by asking that guy to
do a legal thing I don't I still don't
understand that and maybe that's because
there's something in there that was
here's another story here's another good
one Byron York says
it has to lead to an illegal act
eventually doesn't it look at David
Shaffer g-a-g-o-p chair he meets with
Trump quote electors December 14th 2020
explains to the press that electors are
contingent on Trump winning a lawsuit
and that is forgery false statement and
impersonating a public officer that's
what they're charging him with
alternate electors have been done before
this is the Democrats just basically
saying we will do whatever we want and
we will crush you and right now what are
we getting from Republicans in the GOP
angry tweets
fit
angry tweets it's
[Laughter]
I'm looking forward to getting a monitor
in here because I gotta I gotta read
this
yeah so and they want this to go all the
way up you know they want to prolong
this for as long as possible because
ultimately they don't want Trump to the
Republicans well maybe both they want to
preserve order that's for sure so the
Democrats want definitely want Trump and
I mean I don't know
I mean I don't have a whole lot of of
faith in in Trump's ability to to win
like if he's the nominee I'll vote for
him I'm going to vote for whoever's not
the Democrat not Biden um but like I
don't you know I don't I don't see that
that that he's gonna make a whole lot of
uh especially with all of the
indictments I don't see that you don't
think they're getting a lot of people
over you don't think that this motivates
people more to want to vote first not
people that don't not people that don't
already kind of like him if you're not
somewhat uh sympathetic to Trump already
if you weren't I don't think this is
making people sympathetic to him now I
don't think it's sympathetic to Trump
pers I think it's more of a
at this point it's like okay because
he's being indicted all these times I'm
I'm gonna vote for I don't know I I feel
like it's a mind thing I don't think
that you're wrong I think there are
people that do feel that way I don't
know that it's enough to be to win the
presidency yeah okay my opinion I mean
there is no right and wrong I guess
answer but well I mean no you know you
can't know until after until the
election but I I personally don't feel
like I feel like there are people that
strongly want Trump
um and there are people that are always
going to be committed to Trump I just
don't know that they're I don't know
that there are enough people that would
go over to Trump uh that have been in
the middle I just don't know I don't
know who that Vote or the United voter
that goes over is I don't know I've I've
uh it's really funny there are a lot of
people who are terminally online
and uh
these activists online say things like
touch grass and it's like bro you are a
leftist on Twitter who does nothing but
just we like I'm I'm going we go out on
the weekends to various different middle
of nowhere places often and you know we
talk to people who ask them questions
and I found something really interesting
between With Friends of Friends uh
extended family members and just people
out in the General Public
people that I know a couple years ago
who are passively anti-trump have become
passively anti-democrat doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to vote
for Trump but a few years ago you know
we're coming on the back end of of the
coveted lockdowns and the pandemic and
all that they were very much on board
with the corporate narrative
then you kind of destroyed the economy
destroy their trust force them do things
they didn't want to do lock them in a
box and now I'm talking to some of these
people and they're saying things that
are passively anti-establishment
anti-democrat so I don't know where they
end up voting but if Donald Trump
becomes the once again the Avatar of the
anger and frustration of these people he
gets their vote
someone someone tweeted uh a good point
that people aren't necessarily voting
for Trump they're voting for what the
machine hates the most and fears that's
it yeah I watched Trump he did a speech
today I think on Truth social four
minutes he talked about basically about
Joe Biden any of the Biden crime family
talking about 20 million that they got
from Jesus was it China or Ukraine
where's bidens are getting their money
from foreign States and like that's what
people are voting against I think when
you're talking about voting against the
narrative it's voting against a
president who had a son our president's
son was on the board of a in a random
country on Earth some Ukraine halfway
across earth the president's son was on
an energy board in some crazy foreign
country and the guy was a crackhead what
in the and now it's at war with Russia
like what in the hell put these pieces
together uh and that's what people are
voting against if they start if they
vote against them thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at 10 cast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time